it's been almost 40 years since the 1984
version of stephen king's fire starter
blazed through cinemas and it was only a
matter of time in a land of infinite
remakes and reboots till firestarter
arose from the ashes the fire puns will
get worse in this series we take a look
at some of the major differences between
the old and the new so spoilers beware
and if you like this video make sure to
check out my other comparison videos
including one on stephen king's the
stand the basic plot of fire starter is
the same a young girl the daughter of
two people who underwent secret
government testing exhibits a variety of
telekinetic powers chiefly pyrokinesis
in the 84 version charlie mcgee is
played by drew barrymore and in the 22
ryan kira armstrong who you may remember
as being that creepy kid in the latest
season of american horror story drew was
about 8 when she played the role and
ryan 11. before charlie was born her
parents andy and vicki mcgee needed some
extra cash and did what any struggling
college student would do and signed up
for some completely harmless clinical
trials they'd be injected with a
mysterious compound called lot 6 and in
the 84 version we actually see these
trials in fact it's these trials where
andy and vicky first meet and yes that's
heather locklear who plays the mom who's
in the movie for about 30 seconds the 22
version glosses over this part of the
story and instead incorporates it into
the intro credits via interview footage
vicky's part in the new version is
greatly expanded and actually provides a
good foil to zac efron's andy she wants
to teach her daughter how to control her
powers while he wants her to suppress
them so the first 20 or so minutes of
the new version focuses on this family
dynamic how charlie is picked on in
school and the re-emergence of her
powers which seem to have been dormant
for the past three years the 84 version
of the story goes about this rather
differently instead immediately starting
with andy and charlie on the run and
mama firestarter already dead the
elements featuring the mom are told
through flashbacks while in the new
version everything is pretty much told
chronologically so just who exactly are
the mcgees running away from in both
versions it's a group called the shop
which is run by a branch of the us
government called dsi or the department
of scientific intelligence both are
headed by dr joseph wandless and report
to captain hollister and yes that's the
dad from that 70s show and martin sheen
in the 84 version dr wandless has a
larger role and is seen as the voice of
reason against captain hollister who
wants to weaponize children like charlie
in the new version they've made him
mentally unstable kind of like that
crazy guy who warns people you don't
want to go down that road you know he's
right but he's also crazy random
difference music in 84 is done by
tangerine dream and the new version john
carpenter if the 84 version starts with
adam and charlie already on the run then
what's going on in this new one well the
family has basically been hiding since
charlie was born in fact the shop tried
to steal the baby when it was born but
adam used his psychic powers to kill the
kidnappers and the fam has been on the
run ever since none of this is shown in
the old version this event also acts as
a good explanation for why the mcgees
don't have computers or cell phones
since they fear they could be tracked at
any moment but when charlie has a
literal meltdown at school in which he
almost toaster strudel's her teacher the
shop is notified and a special agent is
sent by the shop to bring her in what
we're leading up to here is the death of
charlie's mom in the 84 version a bunch
of shop cronies find their house and
kill her she falls out dead from a
closet in both versions but the new one
weaves in a character known as john
rainbird and the way his character goes
through the story is arguably the new
version's biggest deviation from the
past not only do they correct the
casting the 84 version saw native
american john rainbow portrayed by white
actor george c scott but his background
story and motivations are completely
different in both the book and old
version rainbird has these burn marks on
his face an injury he sustained in
vietnam but the modern version does away
with this and instead makes rain bird a
sort of secret agent under the control
of captain hollister in fact he himself
was a test subject of lot 6 even before
the compound was tested on white college
students referring to him and his fellow
native americans as expendable lab rats
his exposure to this compound resulted
in him having powers which in the old
version he does not so we have andy and
charlie on the run eventually taking
refuge with an old farmer named irv
manders in the new version andy actually
has to use his psychic powers to
convince the farmer to take them in
while in the old he's basically just a
friendly farmer who likes to take
hitchhikers back to his farm but the big
difference here is the farmer's wife who
in the new version is on some form of
life support having sustained injuries
in a car crash that her husband was a
part of although i think this is a
really cool idea to me the new version
missed out on a really heart-wrenching
scene in which charlie's powers could be
used to communicate between irv and his
wife like if i found out a kid could
communicate with my wife who i haven't
been able to talk to for years i would
be willing to protect the [ __ ] out of
that kid in the old version irv just
literally comes out of his house with a
rifle when he sees the shop and
threatens to kill them in the new
version instead of the shop showing up
it's the local police since irv has
called them hearing on the news that
andy is a wanted fugitive the police are
all taken out by rainbird who wants to
bring these two in himself in the old
version it's charlie who defeats the
shop by using her firepowers now this is
where the story really branches off in
two different directions in the old
version both charlie and andy escape
only to be tranquilized and brought back
into the shop's underground lair while
the new version sees charlie escape and
her dad used his bait to lure her back
this creates two very different
scenarios one in which charlie must
escape from captivity and a life of
being tested on to one in which she must
break into the facility to save her
father one is breaking out and one is
breaking in now in the old captivity
scenario john rainberg poses as an
orderly to gain charlie's trust he
basically wants to make it easier to
control her the new version is way
different here he's brought into dsi
custody for killing all those cops and
somehow has the power to telepathically
communicate with charlie who's miles
away i'm not sure how that exactly works
because so far in the story you've only
been able to use these powers if you can
directly look into another person's eyes
this is why you'll see rainbird blocking
his eyes behind this lamp here so that
andy doesn't use his telepathic powers
on him we'll also see members of the
shop use these special contact lenses so
they can't be manipulated by those with
powers so rain bird pretends he's
charlie's father using telepathy to get
her to come to the facility and burn it
all down that's rainbird's secret plan
here he wants revenge for what the shop
did to him charlie easily gains access
to the secret facility by burning the
[ __ ] out of an expecting dad yeah
literally a minute before this guy dies
we hear him on the phone being excited
that his wife is pregnant then he's
burnt to a crisp so charlie can get the
access card and that's another big
difference the charlie in the new
version is extremely unlikable i'm not
saying her acting is bad or anything but
she just does things so irreprehensible
that it's hard for me to connect with
her as a character like there's
literally a scene where she burns a cat
alive and there's also this other scene
which i'm pretty sure was cut from the
movie but was shown in the trailer where
she makes a bird explode now charlie
eventually finds her dad held captive by
hollister and he uses his telepathic
power to control charlie into killing
him and hollister together talk about
really messing your daughter up contrast
this to the old version where it's andy
who tries to escape with his daughter
but ends up getting shot by rain bird in
the process so in each version andy dies
just by different methods this results
in the climax of the film where charlie
goes full carry and destroys anyone in
her path now i gotta say the old version
kicks ass here it's like they put 90
percent of the budget in the final 10
minutes remember this was before cgi so
all the fire effects were done
practically and you have like flaming
dummy corpses flying about real
fireballs and charlie stopping a bullet
and making it explode in this version
charlie kills a rainbird and it's pretty
[ __ ] awesome which couldn't be
further than what happens in the new one
the shop's able to stop charlie by using
these thermal suits and a fantastic idea
turning on the sprinklers and just when
it looks like charlie's going to be
captured again rainbird shoots the
baddies and offers himself up to her
he's done unspeakable things throughout
his life and believes he should be
killed but charlie shows mercy and
simultaneously that she can finally
control this power charlie escapes with
a facility exploding behind her and
collapses in front of a nearby beach
where she's reunited with rain bird and
he carries her off into the distance
that's the end of the new version so in
the old one after her rampage killing
dozens of men she somehow hitchhikes her
way back to the manders farmstead all by
herself from there irv takes her to the
new york times likely to tell her story
about the government's secret tests and
to expose them once and for all so even
though both versions come from the same
source material you can see how
different these two turned out but which
one is your favorite i want to hear your
thoughts in the comments below thanks
for watching everyone be sure to like
and subscribe and check out my other
comparison videos until next time
remember doing it daddy
i love you
you